yeah I need some size and um
interior yeah yeah especially with
Giannis and LeBron James without a
question such a great basketball this
year
I need somebody to offset that I agree
with uh Rudy gobert I agree I agree all
right that worked out nicely that works
yeah I think hey when somebody went out
you let them go don't let them come back
I'm with you KD that's why I cut my hair
off
so uh James Harden goes to uh LeBron
James is the final selection of the
All-Star is he can he is he is he he
hasn't played is he healthy
James he hasn't played what happens he
got traded he's healthy now he's missed
the last three with us with a hammy
see and now we know why Lebron carries a
clipboard with him to the uh oh my God
right now he's rubbing some ice hot on
that thing he's playing the next game